hi alastair thanks for joining us on the
programme am i right in saying that you
went up to dunblane with tony blair when
he was prime minister
no he was leader of the opposition and
we went with john major he was prime
minister
and i think that was
an incredibly powerful signal at the
time a conservative prime minister going
with the leader of the opposition
to show absolute support for the
community of dunblane and i think that
that moment in a way is what justified
politically and helped politically the
legislation that we then brought in when
we were in government um since when
there's not been
uh i think i'm right in saying there's
not been a single incident
in our schools remotely comparable with
the sort of shootings you've been
talking about in america and if there's
one thing i urge you guys at sky to show
today scott you may already have have
shown it but the basketball coach steve
kerr i've just been watching his
uh his comments when he was doing the
pre-match press conference and he made
the point
they go through these things everybody's
tweeting their
thoughts and prayers and everybody's
saying all the sort of cliches that
people roll out of these times but the
kind of exasperation that comes through
and i think was coming through in your
your previous speaker as well it's just
i'll never forget that visit to dunblane
and seeing the sort of the coat pegs and
the coats hanging off the pegs and the
all the sort of paraphernalia of a of a
primary school but it led to change uh
and what seems to me about this what the
guy there call this stalemate in america
and the powerful whole of these
right-wing
very heavily financed lobby groups is
just it's just horrific and it's killing
people
yeah the nra the national rifle
association
let's talk about um some of the
challenges that the prime minister is
going to be facing today finally we
believe that we're going to be seeing
the report from the senior civil servant
sue grey but we basically know what's in
it so isn't it time to move on now
well if we quotes move on as these tory
tory mps keep saying
what it means is that we now live in a
country where the rule of law is not an
inviolable principle in parliament where
it is no longer a principle of our
constitution that a prime minister and
any minister should stand at the
dispatch box
and tell the truth and if they
inadvertently don't tell the truth
correct the record and that says to me
that these tory mps are now propping up
this guy
they are undermining our democracy to an
extent that i don't think we've ever
seen
so i don't think i think if we move on i
think we can say goodbye to the kind of
democratic system that we have
and for what for one guy's vanity and
narcissism and you're right that we know
the basic story because boris johnson
has set the basic story he said right at
the start there were no parties there
was no breach of the rules he was
assured now we know
not only was he
aware of breaches of the rules he was
breaking them himself on a systematic
basis underlining the fact that as far
as he's concerned rules and laws are for
little people and big people
people with power people with wealth
they can do what the hell they want and
every you'll probably have a minister on
later on have these people got any
self-respect whatsoever do they not go
home to wives and husbands and kids who
say to them i'm sorry you cannot defend
the indefensible any longer when you get
i think it's george eustis doing the
round how can these people defend just
play back play back jim k
some of the previous defenses that he's
made when they had a different line and
a different story so it was wait for the
police it turned out he broke the law
then it was wait for sue gray and they
say well whatever sue grey says as you
just said we know the story anyway the
guy is a liar and a charlatan he's doing
nothing for this country in terms of
taking the country forward and the
entire conservative party let me jump in
alistair if i mentioned this
sorry okay let me jump in if i may um
a couple of things really i mean
the prime minister was fined once not uh
several times so the police have looked
at this in detail and they've decided
that it was one
fine that he should pay
you talk about inadvertent
misleading of parliament he says he
didn't know at the time
and then as soon as he did know he came
back to the dispatch box and corrected
himself
he didn't correct himself he came back
and said sorry for the actions of other
people that's what he did and that's
what he always does and the point about
the single fine i'm afraid as sadiq khan
and others said yesterday the
metropolitan police have got a lot of
questions to answer about the extent to
which they investigated this properly
and also okay the one fine is enough to
sink this guy
because he insisted quotes there were no
parties
we know he was at them you don't just
need the pictures you need the testimony
of other people and i'll tell the other
thing that happens i worked in downey
street this would never ever have
happened under tony blair under theresa
may under i think any previous prime
minister this is johnson's character and
johnson's culture so i just don't
believe that when he says when the
police say
you know one fine i think that was them
just trying to get out of this very
difficult situation for them
okay before um
before i let you go um
what do you think is going to happen
because
it would appear that nobody else wants
the job
nobody's certainly challenging the prime
minister so it doesn't matter how much
mod is slung around in the chamber of
the house of commons and on radio radio
programs and tv programs like ours still
going to be in post next week week after
week after that
well i don't know if that's going to
happen or not but if that is the case
then you know i don't want to swear at
this point
time in the morning but this country is
in a very very bad way
if this guy survives
having now is just are we just to accept
as a country is this what our democracy
has come to
a prime minister can break the law a
prime minister can lie repeatedly at the
house of commons dispatch box send out
his cabinet of lap docks to go out and
repeat it for him have we got to a stage
now where there are literally no
principles attached to the basis of our
democracy including the rule of law then
if that is the case we are finished and
tom dukenhart was absolutely right
yesterday what this says is we do not
have a serious functioning government
and if he was doing other great things
the economy was booming inflation wasn't
soaring growth was high none of which is
happening if he was actually leading in
the world if he was actually delivering
on the promises that he made at the last
election he's doing none of that because
the truth is the guy is amoral he's a
liar he's a charlatan he's a crook and
if those tory mps have not got the
slightest bit of self-respect and
integrity and honesty to look in their
hearts and look in their souls and say
are we really going to damage our
country in this way then they deserve to
be kicked out as well